merci de votre présence nous comptons
évoqué ce matin deux points d'actualité
le premier qui ne vous a pas échappé
hier soir qui est évidemment les deux
élections législatives partielles l'une
dans le territoire de belfort l'autre
dans la première circonscription du val
d'oise et le second c'est évidemment le
le prochain déplacement du président de
la république en force qui débute demain
mais il ya alors nous souhaitons salué
la victoire est félicité ian bocar et
antoine savina il ya une book harkis qui
a remporté la législative partielle à
belfort avec 58 93 % et antoine savina
dans le val d'oise avec 51 45% alors le
message a été assez clair le charme de
la république en marche est rompu les
français ont désavoué la politique d'
emmanuel macron et du gouvernement
puisque ces deux élections sont marquées
par une progression par rapport aux
résultats de juin avec pour l'un 5,4
points et l'autre +8 points
alors ce scrutin sanctionne durement le
parti présidentiel et la politique menée
depuis seulement huit mois
edouard philippe s'est engagé et a été
dans un déplacement dans le val d'oise
pour soutenir la candidate avec
christophe castaner il a voulu
nationaliser le débat fidèles à
l'arrogance propre à la république en
marché à ce gouvernement
très sûrs d'eux les les électeurs
envoyer un message très clair ils ont
désavoué edouard philippe et ont revendu
une réponse au niveau national qui est
qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec cette
politique de matraquage de la classe
moyenne et des retraités notamment avec
cette hausse de la csg qui frappe très
durement les retraités les
fonctionnaires également la hausse du
carburants la faiblesse sur la
délinquance tout ce qui touche les
français au quotidien et qui fait que
leur pouvoir d'achat et leur vie
quotidienne s'en trouve s'en trouve en
pâtit donc les républicains ont été unis
lors de cette élection le déplacement de
laurent wauquiez et valérie pécresse ont
permis de montrer que lorsque la droite
est unie lorsque la droite et une aile
gagne et nous sommes heureux de ces
résultats la droite est de retour au
tour de laurent wauquiez
elle est renouvelée elle est déterminée
elle est ancrée et nous pensons que
c'est ce que dans ces deux scrutins
c'est ce qui a été saluée nous allons
poursuivre cette démarche de
reconstruction de la droite avec des
convictions et avec le renouvellement
effectivement c'est un premier signal
d'alarmé populaire pour aider le
maquereau et sa majorité
et c'est aussi effectivement la preuve
que lorsque la droite est unie elle
gagne
lydia toujours là dessus sur la corse
d'abord nous évidemment souhaitons
rendre hommage appuyé à la famille du
préfet erignac
ce préfet qu'il y a vingt ans jour pour
jour demain a été assassiné froid dans
le dos et tous les républicains
souhaitent rendre un hommage appuyé à sa
famille plus la dominique erignac sa
veuve et à ses enfants et nous
souhaitons dire que oui il ya une
identité corse qui doit être respectée
qui doit être prise en considération
mais que cette identité corse doit
s'incarner et se décliner dans l'unité
de la république puisque la république
nous le rappelons est une
et indivisible et qu' il revient
aujourd'hui à emmanuel macron lors de sa
visite en corse qui débutera demain et à
son gouvernement de lever l'ambiguïté
sur les incohérences qui existe entre
d'une part le fait qu'il y ait eu six
élus macro nist qui ont voté la
résolution des autonomistes en corse et
d'autre part les déclarations très
ambigu de christophe castaner le délégué
de la république en marche qui a
désavoué en quelque sorte ses
déclarations tout en disant et en
déclarant ils ne se sont pas trompés on
y comprend plus grand chose sur ce que
veut la majorité emmanuel macron
concernant la corse et nous demandons
clairement à emmanuel macron de lever
l'ambiguïté sur la politique qu'il
entend mener en corse notamment sur
l'ambiguïté que les élus macro nist aux
mises en oeuvre eux mêmes en votant la
résolution des autonomistes
oui donc à une identité corse qui doit
être reconnu et pris en considération
mais cette l'identité doit exister dans
le cadre de l'unité de la république qui
est une et indivisible
cela signifie que nous sommes résolument
opposés à la co officialité de la langue
corse
nous estimons que la république une et
indivisible cela signifie qu'il existe
une seule langue officielle qui est le
français
même si bien entendu il existe des
langues régionales qui
east mais nous considérons il ne doit y
avoir qu'une seule langue officielle qui
est le français
et puis nous considérons aussi qu'il
n'existe pas de prisonniers politiques
dans une démocratie comme la nôtre
les choses sont très claires il n'existe
pas de prisonniers politiques
il ne doit pas y avoir deux langues
officielles
autre que le français nous pouvons
parfaitement prendre en compte le
l'identité corse reste évidemment
emmanuel macron de d'imaginer les
modalités qui peuvent se décliner pour
prendre en compte cette identité mais
nous sommes très clairs la république
est une et indivisible
il n'y en a qu'une et cette identité
corse doit se décliner dans le cadre
d'une unité de la république française
est-ce que sur ce sujet ou sur d'autres
vous avez des questions
on est toujours préoccupé par la faible
participation à une élection quelle
qu'elle soit il vous a pas échappé pour
autant que les participations sont
toujours faibles dans le cadre des
élections législatives partielles
il vous a pas échappé aussi qu'il arrive
souvent d'ailleurs que dans une élection
législative partielle le député sortant
soit conforté ce qui n'a pas été le cas
dans le val d'oise et bien sûr ce sont
deux élections législatives partielles
et que beaucoup de chemin reste à
parcourir
mais lorsqu'on observe sur des
territoires aussi différents que
l'ile-de-france d'un côté et le grand
test de l'autre une remontée
spectaculaire des républicains et une
baisse tout aussi spectaculaire de la
république en marche ou de la majorité
on ne peut pas ne pas en tirer
d'enseignements politique
lydia l'a rappelé un bus de 16
parlementaires de la majorité le premier
ministre lui-même
le numéro un de la majorité c'est à dire
le numéro un de la république en marche
christophe castaner se sont déplacés
donc on a eu même souhaité donner une
signification politique à ce résultat
moi je considère qu'un député est
toujours légitime quelle que soit la
participation à l'élection dont il était
l'objet
bien sûr que nous préférerions qu'il ya
plus de participation mais je crois que
ce qui est un fait politique signifiant
ce sont les résultats et surtout les
tendances et ces tendances sont autant
de signaux d'alert populaire pour
emmanuel macron sans doute une première
sanction populaire infligée à un
gouvernement qui multiplie les annonces
qui pratiquent illusion mais dont les
français ressentent déjà sur le terrain
le décalage entre les déclarations
et les résultats et dont les français
ressentent déjà aussi les premiers
dégâts en termes de pouvoir d'achat de
communautarisme ou de délinquance donc
loin des commentaires élogieux qui sont
faits manière pléthoriques dans les
médias sur la politique emmanuel macron
cette première sanction populaire est
selon nous un fait politique signifiant
qu'ils méritent d'être étudiées et qui
nous l'espérons évidemment méritera
aussi d'être amplifié à l'avenir bonjour
par ici bodo bfm tv sur la question par
exemple du val d'oise c'était une
circonscription qui sauf erreur est
historiquement plutôt à droite c'était
presque une surprise d'ailleurs qu'elle
passe à la république en marche en juin
dernier est ce que finalement ce n'est
pas juste le retour de la normale avec
un score qui n'est peut-être pas si
forte puisque on a 400 voix d'écart sauf
erreur oui vous avez raison c'est dit
circonscriptions de droite la première
circonscription du val d'oise il ne vous
a pas échappé aussi qu' il ya eu un
basculement
dans un grand nombre de circonscriptions
notamment des circonscriptions de droite
lors des dernières élections
législatives partielles et que si vous
même vous dites qu'il y à un retour à la
normale je ne sais pas ce que vous
appelez la normalité mais ça veut bien
dire qu'un retournement de tendance
ça veut bien dire que des électeurs sont
peut-être sincèrement de droite et qui
ont voté emmanuel macron pour un
candidat de la république en marche lors
des dernières élections législatives
pour nous envoyer sans doute un signal
de défiance ont bien compris que la
droite désormais mis en place par
laurent wauquiez était très différente
de la droite d'hier ils ont bien compris
qu avec une équipe renouvelée rajeunie
avec une droite qui a clairement affiché
un signal d'unité avec notamment la
venue de laurent wauquiez et de la
président de la région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse
nous avons tiré les leçons du passé et
je crois qu'il y a deux enseignements à
tirer de cette de cette élection
législative partielle
d'ailleurs tant celle du val d'oise que
celle de belfort c'est que le
renouvellement ça marche c'est à dire
que nous avons des jeunes députés qui
sont sur le terrain ont des jeunes
candidats qui se sont battus qui ont été
épaulés par une droite nouvelle droite
légitimé par la victoire qui est allé
chercher laurent wauquiez dans les urnes
rassemblés à travers l'image de l'unité
entre le notamment laurent wauquiez puis
d'autres figures de la droite est
réaffirmée c'est à dire une droite qui
clair nous avons un premier résultat
cette nouvelle droite produit ses
premiers effets produit ses premiers
résultats
c'est encourageant nous sommes très
conscients qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir mais ce sont des
signaux encourageants
comme ce sont des signaux d'alerté pour
la majorité puisque
c'est dans notamment dans un territoire
aussi bien urbain que rural qui celui là
première circonscription du val d'oise
puisque vous savez cette circonscription
on y trouve à la fois la ville de
pontoise et en même temps les village du
vexin
c'est à dire que ce sont aussi dense et
concentré de france aujourd'hui le
peuple est en train de subir les
premiers dégâts provoqués par le en même
temps par la culture de l'ambiguïté et
par des choix politiques néfastes pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français avec
notamment évidemment l'augmentation de
la csg
les français sont en train de faire les
comptes sur leurs revenus et ils se
rendent compte précisément contre les
déclarations faites par le gouvernement
et leur fiche de paye il y à un décalage
qui commence à devenir préoccupant
donc je crois que ne sous-estimons pas
le la signification de ce fait politique
est aussi bien une sanction à l'égard du
gouvernement
quand un signe encourageant pour la
nouvelle droite que laurent wauquiez a
mis en place
y at il d'autres questions ça vous
laisse pantois
sur la corse je crois qu'on s'est
exprimé bon si elle n'a pas d'autre
merci beaucoup à vous de votre présence